I am from a very small town in Texas
called Newcastle I love Texas
it's my home but it's so limited as to
what you can do so class is really a
doorway to the world I'm jet black heart
I'm the leader of clash babes Clash
babes are an organization of female
players of clash of clans and we come
together where we set up a war with
another clan a lot of guys think that
they're going to go up against the clash
babes and it's gonna be an easy win
black hearts going down just say that
once the war gets started one balloon
remaining up there not good they realize
we're just as badass as everyone else
it's not just about clash but it's the
social aspect and how global it is um
ego yeah
I need inclusive that I feel comfortable
with my - favor eat them together as a
team who is hurt ours and exposing I'll
do those last we help ready for the
bank's war they like me who I ain't I'll
talk to you after a while I am so proud
of the clash babes we have come so far
it is a constantly ever-changing
evolving mix of awesome women we've got
classmates from all over pretty much
every state in the United States there's
Egypt the Sudan India England Scotland
Ireland Sweden Serbia Indonesia the
Philippines but there's a lot of other
women out there because you can never
have too many such babes
[Music]